il faut pas oublier que la technologie
numérique permet à tout le monde pour
jeunes évidemment de faire des choses
assez extraordinaire de participer à des
communautés à toutes sont documentés de
faire des projets de créer de collaborer
de socialiser puis d'ailleurs si ce que
le thème d'une éducation médias cette
année et c'est de souligner parce que
quand les produire et créer c'est à dire
qu'est ce qui arrive quand on apprend
aux jeunes comment produire écrit des à
partir des médias numériques
quel effet ça peut avoir justement sur
leur utilisation des médias à la base
d'un secteur
c'est que ça permet aux jeunes enfants
comprennent notamment quelque chose ici
mais là ça ça nous permet d'avoir une
pensée critique plus développée par
rapport à ce média l'appui de des plus
résistants justement aux essais d'un
potentiel de ses meilleurs à ce que les
jeunes font de bien déjà les médias
sociaux ou avec la technologie en
général il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
choses de temps par exemple dans un nous
rapporte ont ainsi le cas on voulait
savoir si les jeunes par exemple savez
protéger leur vie privée
en général les jeunes ont compris ce
message là ils savent protéger leur vie
privée
d'ailleurs ils sont assez conscients
puis quand même assez sophistiqué dans
leur façon de contrôler qui peut voir
quoi sur internet surtout dans les
médias sociaux loup
par exemple il reste du travail à faire
c'est de l'art et d'un comprendre
comment ces sites qui sont pour la
plupart des sites commerciaux récolte
des données mais puissamment cette année
là sont utilisés qu'est ce que ces
données là pour est essentielle ment le
avoir comme conséquence il ya lieu de
travail